senior fellow at the Gatestone Institute
author of the upcoming book War China is
going to war Gordon uh the Beijing
bailout you say something like that has
been tried by past presidents how did it
all work out for us we did that in 1972
with Nixon
um George H.W bush in 1989 and Bill
Clinton in 1999 three rescues of the
Communist Party well we thought by being
generous China would reciprocate well no
it just used the respite to actually
strengthen itself and become more
hostile this is the biggest diplomatic
mistake in U.S history The grandest
Wager and clearly we have an East Coast
establishment that wants to continue it
you know Brett Stevens talking about
being magnanimous towards the Chinese
which really means being pretty awful to
American workers
well um when you when you think about
this brics uh meeting that took place I
guess Putin didn't attend but what he
phoned in or something how significant
is this there are some people say oh
it's not a big deal but isn't that a
direct assault on Americans preeminence
in the world as a global superpower if
it continues to expand like they want it
to especially the D dollarization well
China certainly wants it to to move in
that direction and then China certainly
wants to de-dollarize the world we got
to remember that Biden has opened the
door to this you know if we worry about
de-dollarization we worry about the
Petro dollar
Biden made Saudi Arabia an enemy Trump
had the greatest relations with Saudi
Arabia that's not an exaggeration and
then you turn around and Biden tries to
make them a pariah so now Muhammad bin
Salman the Crown Prince he's retaliating
by trying to buy and sell oil in in U.N
and also Brazil
Lula de Silva the new president of
Brazil he is trying to de-dollarize the
world he never would have been elected
if Biden didn't help him over his
predecessor so we've opened the door to
de-dolarization matter of fact Biden did
and that when people are hearing the
phrase dedolarization I don't think most
people understand what that would really
mean to them to their families to their
budgets how would this play out in terms
of dollars and cents well what what it
means is that the world doesn't use the
dollar which means that we got to borrow
in somebody else's currency which always
is a risk more expensive a much more
expensive puts the U.S really at risk of
default
um and also interest rates are going to
go up well beyond where they are right
now the U.S loses a lot of diplomatic
leverage because we do use the dollar
not only for sanctions but also for
other means as well so the U.S in a
world where the dollar is not dominant
is a world of hurt for the average
American
well and Gordon finally uh when we see
Biden send four officials top officials
to Beijing after the balloon
surveillance uyghur genocide crushing
freedom in Hong Kong and all these
liberals here in the United States AOC
where are all these people we're the
progressives they used to say they cared
about human rights yeah well they
certainly don't care about genocide and
crimes against humanity and these
atrocities are the worst since the Third
Reich but it also means Biden is trying
to show the Chinese I guess that we
think we're a supplicant because that's
the way Xi Jinping views it when we send
four senior officials to China without a
return visit by a senior official to
Washington this is really bad diplomacy
and really what it's making is Xi
Jinping much more aggressive which means
that he very well may start a war
because he doesn't respect the United
States anymore thinks we're weak Gordon
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else